hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one shot now one shot is
easily one of the highest-rated games
I've ever seen on Steam it has over a
thousand reviews all glowing saying it's
an amazingly immersive world that breaks
the fourth wall and pulls you in and
it's kind of 98 percent so by all
standards people say that it's very very
good so I'm eager to see what we have in
store for us here should I use a gamepad
now I am good let's do this
but then explore and interact with the
environment and characters sometimes you
may find an item once you've picked it
up an item you may select it from your
inventory when the item is active you
can either combine it with your other
items in the inventory or use it as
certain locations in order to progress
although full screen is an option the
game is best experienced in windowed
mode closing the game will save your
progress this game also auto saves after
some key offense really this is what I'm
thinking I don't know a lot about the
game but it said something about
breaking the fourth wall is that why
it's best experienced in windowed mode
is it going to do something to me hello
okay hi how are you doing oh huh
hello
and who is anybody there I can't move
there we go
okay input password I don't know the
password to my own computer so I'm going
to go with that access tonight I can't
imagine why hello dusty books it's too
dark to read in here really is it well I
can turn on the light but that'd just be
a waste of power there's a TV remote
here nico picks it up so my name is nico
huh wow what am i doing in this
destitute room this is my room
hello bathroom how you doing a wizard
plant sits here stiff and dry a branch
snaps off do I take that a pair of
luminous yellow I step back in nikko are
those my eyes there's no water in the
toilet tub won't run this place is a
what are we doing here the door
is locked
well I guess I'm gonna be stuck here for
a while maybe I could just go back to
bed maybe I don't even remember where I
came from maybe I don't even remember
who I am so I got a television remote
too hard to read in the dark light a
flaky dry branch from the bathroom so I
do have that branch that's going to help
me in the long run I know I'm going to
be doing a lot with this branch but
maybe I can read maybe I can read the
these can be combined
[Music]
a bogey in the faint light Niko can
glimpse the face of the remote all the
numbers except 9 8 1 & 4 are missing so
if I remember the order correctly 9 8 1
& 4 9 is red 8th is blue one is yellow
green is 4 9 is red a tizzy 8 is blue
one is yellow green is 4 8 is blue for
this is one that's nine got it got it I
get a puzzle everybody be happy for me I
don't you don't have to be happy for me
I'm just saying like everybody in my
head be happy for me oh hello you
found me yeah I did hide-and-seek silver
let's get back home why you're already
too late not much of the world remains
this will go this will you parent went
to you outside this place was never
worth saving do you still want to try
then remember this your actions here
will affect Nico whoa I thought you were
talking to Nico there you're talking to
me your actions here will affect Nico
your mission is to help Nico leave and
most importantly you only have one shot
mark don't do that to me don't you do
that to me no no no that's bad oh okay
ah I only have one shot I was wondering
if the name of this game was gonna be
anything like the you only have one
chance flash game oh boy oh no oh no
hello everybody my name is markiplier
how are you doing the TV gives off a
dangerous looking spark so I gotta be
careful with this because if I only have
one shot I could mess everything up very
easily the wood in the fireplace looks
like it was never used perhaps it could
be lit fam maybe
mmm box tasty all right let's skedaddle
over here inside the refrigerator is a
bottle of alcohol
nigo takes it time to party the night
away because this world is going through
hell
it's the table just a chair alright then
sink won't turn on nothing over there I
think I've looked at pretty much
everything in here what is that that's a
big keyhole the biggest keyhole I've
ever seen maybe I could poke my branch
in there oops
all right hand get this put that stick
it in there get it in there
stick it in there go on don't be shy
come on
alright fine then there's got to be
something else that I can do Nikki hit
me go ready for the branch
it doesn't manage to light oh I forgot
there was a spark coming from that a
maybe if I combine nip Nico dips the
branch Nico dabs it in there so if I use
that on this it'll light on fire ah
alright and then I've got lit flame oh
that that doesn't look good
that on the glimmers on the ground is
smallest metallic object wedged it into
the crack in the floor Nico digs it out
what did I get a basement key okay and
an empty bottle wait did the sink run I
can't even remember if it ran let me see
if I can put it in there no it didn't
work at all but maybe I could put it
over here yes I can I don't want to go
in there just yet I want it see if I
could fill the bottle up man it's so
cool by the way
but things won't turn on so there's no
point in doing that but I do have an
empty bottle and I can remember that as
I go farther into this also if you
notice this seems to be no safe mechanic
which I'm assuming it means it saves
automagically
but I don't know what I'm getting myself
into so I don't even know if I'm gonna
come across the decisions they had a
light bulb hello alrighty then grab that
sweet nice a light bulb whoa
[Music]
Niko has some magic powers that I didn't
know about tip it about me to be a bit
about what I got like it's really quiet
now all of a sudden I thought it was a
little that's right here last time I
went through this no it's it's just it's
really quiet why is it so quiet down
there all I can put it in there I book
it's the Sun do you mean that
legitimately like it's the Sun I don't
know if I want to put it in here just
yet because I can go in the other room
and I can read the books now I should be
able to anyway
ad infinitum ad infinitum I don't know
what that means
alright then I just don't know if
there's absolutely anything else that I
need to see maybe I could shine a light
out the window and someone could find me
here
ad to infinite them okay all right so I
just take this light bulb and I pop it
in that bad boy oh mama do
[Applause]
hello
squeaky squanchy or am i now what's left
of a computer terminal how did I get
here there's no door how did I get here
what does that just fit the edge of the
abyss all right oh hello what that huge
and tall and probably a metaphor for
something you can quickly travel to
locations you've already visited by
selecting the fast travel option and
menu the default key for opening the
menu is a fast travel cannot be used
indoors okay good then a robot it no
longer has power
so this world has the technology for
robots bender weird shimmering light
from the walls what's left of a robot
[Music]
fascinating yeah so wire I guess I was a
loading screen oh man what else what am
I doing here is this ah the light bulb
you are here me yes welcome to our world
friend I'm most humbled by your presence
yes thanks sorry I'm a little lost
oh right allow me to explain some things
man first ask how you arrived here I'm
not sure I woke up in this weird house
it was really dark
oh so you woke up in an unfamiliar dark
location mm-hmm just as my prophecy
fulfilled yes you are the savior we've
been waiting for you'll be the one to
save our world from the eternal darkness
that's a lot of put on my shoulders I
will now provide you with vital
information please ask me anything I'm
like a reddit AMA oh well can you tell
me about this one
I'm not sure where I am exactly I can't
see too far off everything's so dark our
world was not always this dim nor was it
so broken time waits for nobody not even
saviors the world is divided into three
regions you're on the fringe right now
the Barrens that's how you see in the
distance once held our Sun Oh
so that's what the tall thing as you go
further towards the center you will
cross the other regions there should be
a map still in its output somewhere ah
can you tell me about the light bulb
found it in the house I woke up in
within your hands is our new son your
son yes years ago our previous son sat
atop that Tower
and spilled its life into the land but
one day the light went out oh the world
is still hanging on by a thread the
surface of this world is abundant with
an element called phosphor fortunately
for us this elements stored light energy
from our previous Sun it's now our only
source of illumination but its energy is
finite when the last of the light dies a
world will - oh I missed that sorry but
now that you're here with the new Sun
all is well
you will need to restore it to the tower
that looks pretty far off yes show
begins your pilgrimage also the Sun is
fragile - please be careful if the Sun
shatters the world will end in an
instant Oh can you tell me about the
computer in the house I found this
computer Kings kept saying stuff like
your actions here will affect Nikko
but I'm Nico all those messages meant
for someone else hmm if I had to guess
they might be trying to pass the message
to mark mark ah that would be our God
yay
finally the recognition I deserve if you
are here that means mark is here also
mark will provide guidance for your
journey
in fact they already have really I
haven't seen anyone though have you not
contacted market
I don't think so being the bringer of
our son you have the secret ability to
communicate directly with mark an
ability that no one else possesses
suddenly not I please close your eyes
and focus all right I'm gonna talk to
mark me hello mark are you there as god
me markiplier was up yes that is not my
name that is not my name at all oh well
what is your name then it is it is
simply markiplier your lord bargain liar
nice to meet you markiplier my name is
Nico ha got it I actually heard someone
it said their name is markiplier though
this is incredible it seems the record
name was incorrect updating database hmm
pit complete do not be afraid to ask
markiplier for assistance and neither
should you
you are the Messiah after all can you
tell me about going home oh I don't mean
to be rude but I'm not sure about this I
still don't know how I got here I was
just with my mama a few hours ago and
now it feels like I'm in a bad dream I
just want to go home
your mission is to save our world just
as my mission is to tell you about our
world I am unable to help you beyond my
programming I am sorry
oh I think that's all I have for ask for
now excellent I wish you luck
all righty then hello again are there
more questions you wish to ask hmm can
you tell me about the bear it's so empty
here that's why it's called the Barrens
are there any people living in this area
sighs robots I mean I do not know I was
not built to wander not built - so you
just stand here must be boring you at
least have friends robot friends I
cannot desire companionship I have not
been tamed not tamed there was no time I
see hello again
then we'll question oh man it's kind of
sad for this guy so what is this
prophecy exactly the Prophet predicted
that a savior will arrive from another
land
the Savior will wake up in a strange
house find the Sun and illuminate the
world Oh what else did you foresee what
do you mean what else did you see in the
prophecy but uh wait you are the Prophet
right good heavens no please called it
my prophecy earlier that just means it
is built into my programming your what
ah my programming is what guides me I am
a robot after all I see
unless question asked how tall is the
tower
I can't even see the top I am not
allowed to answer that question but how
do I get up there in time
markiplier will know what to do I see ya
markiplier dev never really knows what
to do
alrighty then so weird god it's blowing
my mind right now robot without power oh
it won't turn on
there's just no power in general it
seems to be ok just done that power
alright then that's good to know
this box looks interesting I wish I had
something to pry it open with I have
what do I have I have an empty bottle
I'm going to smash it over it
alright I'm gonna smash it with the
lightbulb I carry then nevermind self
charging solar battery model number 87
one-year warranty included simply place
your self charging battery in full
daylight with the lens facing up charges
in seconds no external powers needed if
the battery fails to charge check to see
if the lens on the side
has not been dislodged during transport
one charge cycle will last about 10 days
if you notice a decline in the charge
cycle within the warranty period please
contact the manufacturer all righty then
weird a robot may not injure a living
person or through inaction allow a
person to come to harm too a robot must
obey the orders given to it by people
except where such orders would conflict
with the first law a robot must protect
its own existence as long as such
protection does not conflict with the
first or second law so those are the
three laws of robotics oh map of the
world the tower just keeps going up holy
is so cool like already I'm barely
scratching the surface of this game and
I the world is huge hard to do that so
quickly the use of a robot as our
replacement head engineer seems
unorthodox
especially for the one responsible for
last year's incident
I suppose they had to get her away from
the city but that doesn't make it easier
to swallow for those of us who work here
I hope that man knows what he's doing
I mean maybe I don't know who you're
talking about so the faded poster
reminded all workers the rarest form of
blue phosphor is found during the spas
for shrimp spawn period if you observe a
pond with a bubble over service please
contact management immediately we will
dispatch a harvesting ASAP all right
they need fox-fur - faded poster five
new positions available at the mines
housing and other provisions are
included upon hiring first-come
first-serve I bet that's because people
died does the shelves
there's nothing but dusty shelves all
through here hello what do we have here
a page with faded ink able to provide
power to all robots machinery in an area
via a large electromagnetic field
maintenance efforts are quite high as
expected we have provided customized
backup cells for the few most important
robots their electromagnetic fields are
much weaker and the signals are highly
specific in other words these small
cells can only charge one single
probably one single dot there are a lot
of small glowing shrimp in the jar
interesting some sort of small machine
and wonder what it does I can feel my
hair standing up a little so that's
probably providing power the big machine
doesn't seem to be doing anything though
rectangle shaped hole in the middle like
something used to fit here I bet that's
what those one of those rechargeable
batteries fits in there that's what they
were talking about before
nothing but dusty shelves so I've got to
find the battery maybe I could take it
out of here maybe I could take the power
out of there no okay gonna move on try
to find something else man mines of the
Barons hello what is this ah I don't
like this we're about sitting on a
conveyor belt no power robot okay just
doesn't have power and none of these
things have power everything just ran
out when the light goes out I guess
everything just stops
makes you wonder what has it's going to
happen when our Sun runs up let's use
the crush metal maybe a recycling plan
of some sort or an assembly clamp robot
beyond repair what's that sound
oh it's still working I don't know why
hello can I stop you why would you want
to smash a bottle here markiplier the
shards would get everywhere well I could
smash the lightbulb market wire I am NOT
gonna put the Sun here okay
I just got an achievement chaotic evil
good for me alrighty then didn't mean to
do that
just ahead yikes alright so there's got
to be some sort of metal piece that I
can crush in that thing just not the
bottle of the bulb that would be that
would be reckless and probably kill
everybody in this entire world and I
don't want to do that oh hello oh cool
that must be with the shrimp code that
those tracks seem a little wonky no
nothing there
what does that leave I don't even know
where I'm going I don't even know if
there's a place that I'm supposed to be
going all I know is that I'm going
although the poisonous gas is highly
localized into vent zones barren workers
were still recommended to wear gas masks
these guys masks were mandatory around
active vent sites of course as more and
more the workforce got replaced by
robots we con ourselves with the surplus
of abandoned gas masks it seemed like a
waste to get rid of them all so we kept
a few for emergencies all right good to
know I guess so does that mean that
there's going to be gas masks that I
might need in the future I I don't know
wait there's something over there hello
what do we have here a metal safe seems
like it's locked with a six digit code
nah I got nothing I know that wasn't it
I know my guidance has led you astray
I'm sorry I'm not all-knowing
I mean where am I going why this is a
labyrinth of mazes extract act act act
act act so the mining operations going
smoothly materials are no longer our
limiting factor we will be able to build
more resilient robots both in body and
mind specifically the discoverer of
metal alloy 291 will likely allow the
development of highly efficient
circuitry okay good thing for metal
alloy two nine one then I guess Oh
to what end you know like to what end
why did the light go out in the first
place who put it out if someone put it
out or did it just burn out why is there
Sun just a light bulb whoa hello a robot
no power just like the rest
in a field of clovers wait what is that
what is that all we've got like a shovel
digger thing yeah weird
where am I go hi are you the light bulb
so are you the Messiah
that's what I've been told I expected
someone taller that's what I hear every
time I walk in the room or at least
someone that doesn't look like a kid
that's what you are right some sort of
cat no I'm a person you got the eyes of
a cat a cat looking for legs well either
way a child like you being Messiah just
feel right but that robot said back
there says there's no mistake I know
it's going to sound cold but I honestly
think you're better off just leaving and
letting the world die naturally the
world has been falling apart for a long
time this manner of decades highly
unprompted son conviction you've already
seen how bad it can get right we haven't
seen much of anything actually and we
can't really just leave oh so you just
got here then you must be headed towards
the tower mm-hmm that's who I'm supposed
to put the light bulb you're done isn't
it yes at the very top we know that the
tower contains a force that nobody could
comprehend it and the power is strongest
at the summit maybe it will send you
back home after you complete your
mission oh don't take my word for it
though all right well what should i do
then all right
thanks for talking to me sorry for
intruding on your house your silver
heard the news about the mines I'm sorry
I can't imagine what you're feeling
spend two weeks I know it must be hard
but maybe it's better you came back it's
only a matter of time before the robots
are recalled at least let me know you
got my message okay Kip
please do not touch that sorry I got
curious what is this thing back up power
stuff keeps me functional the main
generator for the barons ran out of
power some time ago it could not even
last a week without the Sun sorry to
hear that all we can do is make you to
the light we have really shelf of weird
tools and pieces of metal something
that's poking out from the shelf the
screwdriver you can take it if you want
it may help you are you sure yes I have
many thank you so I got a crew driver
hey maybe I can crush it in the middle
crusher lots of tiny shrimp are swimming
in this jar huh so weird what's inside
the tower I don't know nobody's ever
entered it before at least nobody nobody
history knows then who built it built as
far as anyone can tell it's been there
since the beginning of time I know
someone who wanted to study it before
but oh he never told me you should one
anywhere oh I photo of two people the
glass is a bit too foggy to see the
details though a shelf of weird tools
the metal chest table covered and dust I
haven't played chess with anyone for a
very long time
not even with other robots No
nobody in the Barrens have that capacity
in their programming nobody here is
tamed for that matter what is paining is
that that person a robot create the bed
that's metal doesn't look very
comfortable
I'm using a robot would meet comfort do
you need further assistance we're good
thanks
Oh speak for me Niko I want to ask
questions okay well I got a screwdriver
I guess I could head back I am feeling
like I missed a lot of stuff back there
so I might as well take this and
reconvene but I like I'm so confused
about this world what is it like what
does it entail what's happening here and
and like it's so weird cuz it's
acknowledging that I'm literally helping
to do something in this world I don't
even know what but I'm doing something
Marga bar there's something in the air
here it hurts to breathe
ah we need a gas mask for that me and my
divine knowledge gleaned something from
a note that you may have missed about a
surplus of gas man maybe you want to go
flying that but first there's a note
over here on this twisty windy road and
then up never mind I guess I already got
that one I must have got that one I
think I don't even remember where I've
been on this windy road well this is
just a dead end we'll damn it Morgan
lawyer should have known about that
markiplier apologizes for oversight
markiplier should have a better memory
about these things okay yeah I've been
here maybe I could use the jar or like
the bottle that I have now to take that
try to scoop up some now because I
imagine that full of shrimp and the only
source of life that they have are these
weird glowing shrimp and that's
literally all they have for solar energy
and besides the tower and this Sun that
I'm holding in my hands which is such a
weird concept to think about like first
why is that tower there why does that
tower only run with this light bulb and
where did I come from the make it happen
and where do I the person the player
fall into all this like what does it
mean why is it all here like what's my
purpose here oh hello
well that's where I came from so what's
the rest of it is there anything even
over here
apparently answer is yes okay answers
yes I don't know where I'm going but all
right and so is there still more light
as you go towards the center it's a
metal pipe must have broken off from one
of these terminals well I got some metal
to smash I'm going to smash it up I'm a
little tired from walking is it alright
if I take a nap yeah go ahead go for it
oh my god why the game just closed
trying to load it back up he's not
working right the networking load little
please on the game okay oh hi oh hello
who's beautiful
oh hi
Margot why are you still there yes I am
here I was worried for a moment
ah I'm awake I had a dream just now I I
was watching it he did wow I I really
thought I was back home oh the Sun back
in my home world isn't a light bulb it's
a big ball of fire in the sky I don't
think I would be able to hold it like I
would do if with the Sun from your world
this isn't my world hi this is in the
world I live in
really oh I guess not if you're the God
in this world you wouldn't necessarily
be in it
what's your home called figure it no
earth called Earth like the stuff from
the ground way do you live on the ground
yeah III say no I neither do we but
shrews and field mice acceptive if you
will have a son yes it's also a ball but
why wouldn't I be able to tell Nikko
that what would happen if I lied to him
I'm not mentally prepared for these
choices really Wow can you hold it no
that was a silly question wasn't it yeah
very silly the Sun in my home world is
very bright warm too
you saw right but it goes away sometime
tonight
cuz I think it's dark kind of like how
this world is now but it's okay because
the Sun always comes back the next day
that's good don't you think
yeah my world is like that too
ahh you sleep during the night we go to
sleep usually some people stay up and
use computers I wouldn't know anything
about that
I'm very productive and sleep hold it I
don't have to explain what they are do i
there's a bunch of them in this world
anyway we should probably get going
okay I guess man
I'm so cool god that's cool I'm friggin
cool oh that's cool I like it already
but I know I know I'm going to find some
way to mess this up and I really don't
want to I want to play this hook here
because I'm willing to bet I'm only
reminded of the game you only have one
chance to save the world from that
disease that you made that killed your
whole family you remember that game that
I played a while back huh man I wasn't
prepared for that one either but I'm
gonna do my best here I really am so let
me know what you think of this game down
in the comments below try not to spoil
it for anybody else just keep in mind
there's a lot of new experiences coming
out of this and I'm I'm really excited
to see this I really am excited to see
this because this is something special
and I can already tell it's gonna blow
my mind right now oh it already is I'm
the god of this world and yet I school
scared so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
the section will record your progress in
this world to return again to this world
you need to relaunch the application
proceed
sure oh my god oh no did I just kill
Nico I got have no idea okay
alright I'm assuming everything's okay
okay I'm fine bye